Smash or Pass?
What a great idea of a video.
I'm sure that's not going to have any consequences whatsoever.
Personally or online.
Uh
You know it's not going to be awkward when I meet these people in real life.
After I judged them whether I would stick my dick in them or not.
I think, you know, this is such a fucking good idea.
For anyone over the age of fucking sixteen or, or
or any fucking age of that matter to me.
It's smash, marry, or sell to slavery. That's how it goes.
I didn't make this list by the way so uh, keep in, keep in mind
*Squishy*
Uh, nothing personal, okay?
Let's take it step by step.
Here we go.
Jack Spedicy.
Starting off strong.
Uhmmm
Hard pass, hard pass.
Tana Mongeau.
Sell to slavery.
Tana: You fucking n*gger
OH MY GOD. TANA WHAT ARE YOU- HOW DARE YOU CALL ME THAT WORD. IM ABOVE THAT, OKAY? I DONT SAY THE N WORD *LIES*
Ssniperwolf
uhhhhhhhhhh
*thinking*
I would give here the Ermac Fatality
*Kinky shit*
What can I say, I'm into kinky shit
Jessica Nigiri
More like, Jessicaaa, uhhh,
NOGRI
SELL DAT BITCH TO SLAVERYYY
*Much Better :)* I'm kidding i'm sorry i mean SELL THAT LADY TO SLAVERYYY
*propaganda*
MARKIPLIER (We need another fanfic read!)
I would give the fattest dick
I would love to have a non-sexual relationiship with mark where
We just eskimo kiss (Shipping intesifies) and sometime finger each others butthole ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
KSI
SELL TO SLAVERRYYY
Oh, (rip headphone users)
*KSI sound*
Dan and Phil- This is fun, im enjoying this just judging the fuck out of people
lets see here, dan and phil (C H I L D R E N) hmmmmm
I would SELL THEM TO SLAVERYYY PLEASE
Actually I would marry Phil, (Take a ticket and wait your turn Poods)
he seems lovely (Let's set sail)
uhhhh dan however, uh hehe yaaa
SELL DAN TO SLAVERYYYYYY
*Mario power up*
Eyy i'm in there!
oh man what can I say, I would, I would uh, give the fattest dick *have to wait a lil bit longer, Pewds; cloning's just 'round the corner ;)*
Supermom-woman! would smash... with a sledgehammerrr *why cant we be friends begins to play. WHY cant weee be friends why cant weee be friends...*
why does everyone have it against me? I don dunno understanddd T_T
you dont understand
filthy frank
*pewds.exe has stopped working*
wait, who's that? (Nice defense poods)
sexyphil
I would just have a serious talk about your username
I would pretend to befriend you, and then just STAB YOU IN THE BACK.
Zoella
Scorpion fatality, I'm gonna have to go with Scorpion fatality on that one.
*More happy music and more kinky shit*
I would have her write my book, my next book... I will have her write it.
Keemstar
SELL TO SLAVERYYY
oh what-what?
wait
oh keemstar
SELL TO SLAVERYYYY
*gets interrupted by phone, rude*
hello?
Alex, yayayay he's on the market now. Yea, got her, got a good price for ya. 18. NONONONONONONONO DON'T HANG UP GOD DANG IT.
Jenna Marbles
I WOULD SMASHSHHH that like button haha love her videosssss
I'm sweating, it'ss lol I'm trying really harddd Marzia pleaseeeee
MARINA JOYCE
I would dance, I would dance with Marina
Zoey BURGERRRRRRrRrRrRr
I would uh, I would umm, DRINK CYANIDE WITH ZOEY
RiceGummmm
SELL TO SLAVERYYYYYYY
wait, no actually, didn't he recently get exposed for having a ghostwriter for all his diss tracks
didn't he get exposed for viewbotting as well?
then there's the whole fouseytube thing that happened
he's getting exposed for everything, what's next, he's not asian, he's actually white? (oh shiet)
Marzia (yesssssss)
*dank af music starts*
oh, well, that's easy.
PASSSSSSSSSSSSSSSS
FAKE MARZIA
SMASHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
SMAHSSSSHSHSHSSSHSHSHSH
SMASH IJSUDHLSAUDHSJGHSKGHADUGSLUGSGYUDSUOASO
SO FUCKING HARD
LOOK AT THAT BITCH
I WOULD TAKE THAT WHITEE BIATCH TO STARBUCKSSSS AND THROATFUCK THAT BITCH ALL FUCKING NIGHT.
Sorry, what happened?
That was Smash or Pass,
Would you smash or pass me *hehe*
leave a comment down below what you would do
To this face.
watch another video, that way, this video will get more promotion
it's how the algorithm works
Don't like the video
fucking don't.
STOP.
just click here.
GO
JUST GOOO *DO IT*
GOOOOOOOO
FUUUUU